There are those who walk among us...
...who are champions of discovery,...
...agents of change,...
...and curators of passion.
They challenge us to ask questions like "what," "why" and "how."
They encourage us to explore beyond our backyard,...
...and they captivate our minds and nurture our curiosities.
Because of them, we better understand our world.
We know what causes an earthquake,...
...why a light bulb lights,...
...how clouds produce rain.
They reassure us that it is okay to think without boundary...
...and explore the possibilities of what could be.
There are those who walk among us who inspire us...
...to investigate, to create, to find solutions,...
...to become part of and ultimately, change our world.
For all the things you do,...
...for who you are and for who you inspire us to become,...
...we offer our most sincere thank you to you, our teachers.
The GLOBE Program is proud to partner and interact with a worldwide community of inspiring teachers...
...who cultivate interest and the love of learning through interaction...
...and hands-on engagement and investigation of Earth.
Join us in thanking educators everywhere.
Share this with your friends, family, and favorite teacher today.